à dijon reprise demain devant la cour
d'assises de la côte d'or du procès de
jean marie villemin procès qui devrait
durer encore environ un petit mois après
les témoignages dignes et douloureux des
parents de grégory et de l'épousé de
bernard laroche
les autres membres de la famille
villemin vont témoigner cette semaine le
point avec dominique verdeilhan et bruno
girodon le silence et les mots le
silence seulement troublée par le
crépitement des flashs quand christine
villemin sort du palais de justice
les mots quelques minutes plus tôt dans
la salle d'audience je voudrais
tellement trouver les mots justes pour
dire la souffrance qu'on a vécu pourtant
les mots justes christine villemin les
trous pour dire devant la justice son
amour au champ maryse pour rétorquer aux
avocats de la famille laroche qui dès
cette première comparution voulu
déstabiliser christine villemin
en vain des mots d'amour et des mots de
douleur comme se dit la veille par jean
marie quand il s'agit de parler de
grégory desmot dur est sans appel quand
il s'agit de la famille laroche
nous ne voulions pas les fréquenter chez
eux c'était toujours la bringue
ils ne pensaient qu'à boire des mots
pour inverser les rôles définis par les
règles judiciaires pour dire que les
victimes sont dans le box et les
responsables en face dès demain la foule
sans cesse plus nombreux ce prêt sera de
nouveau on se précipitera dans la salle
des pas perdus pour y entendre les
dépositions des parents et frères de
jean marie villemin
jacky demi-frère au centre des missives
du corpo michel qui le 16 octobre 84 a
été le premier prévenu de l'enlèvement
du petit grégory monique la maire albert
le père premières cibles des lettres
anonymes
demain les jurés auront devant eux
l'arbre généalogique commun aux familles
villemin laroche bolle depuis neuf ans
la justice n'a qu'une seule certitude le
nom du coupable y est inscrit